Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Mais qui est Le Corbusier ?
Charles-Édouard Jeanneret-Gris, né à la
Chaux-de-Fonds, à quelques pas d’ici.
Né dans une famille d’horlogers,
une mère musicienne,
un frère virtuose de la musique
et lui qui doit trouver sa voie.
Sous la houlette de Charles
L’Eplattenier, qui le guide,
il se lance dans la gravure -
graveur sur boîtier.
Et au fil du temps, il s’essaie
au dessin, à la peinture,
à différentes choses.
Il aimerait devenir peintre, mais Charles
L’Eplattenier ne le voit pas en peintre.
Pas assez de talent.
Donc, il lui recommande
de partir vers l’architecture.
Il arrête l’école d’art
et il part voyager.
À son retour de voyage, il commence
à construire des maisons
grâce à l’aide d’autres architectes
qui sont conseillés
par Charles L’Eplattenier.
La première maison : la Villa Fallet.
La deuxième : la Maison Blanche.
La Villa Fallet,
dans un style Sapin que
L’Eplattenier a bien développé.
Puis la Maison Blanche
qu’il construit pour ses parents.
Au fil du temps, il voyage encore :
il va en Grèce, en Turquie.
Il va à Berlin, Munich, Paris.
Il rencontre des frères Perret
qui sont plutôt dans le béton.
Il apprend, il apprend
et il continue d’apprendre.
Ses 30 premières années
lui permettent d’acquérir
un petit savoir-faire en architecture
qu’il met au service de la villa Schwob.
Monsieur Schwob était
un industriel chaudronnier.
M. Schwob invite Le Corbusier
pour redessiner le plan.
Ils ont un certain budget,
mais malheureusement,
M. Schwob aimerait plus de choses.
Le Corbusier, il accepte.
Il est jeune, il ne comprend pas
encore comment dire non.
Arrive ce qui arrive :
à la fin du gros œuvre,
ils ont déjà dépensé l'ensemble du budget.
Il se fait démettre de ses fonctions.
Il reste l'architecte de l'œuvre.
Il peut continuer à suivre l'œuvre,
mais il risque beaucoup.
À cette époque-là, si on se fait attaquer,
qu’on est poursuivi
et qu’on ne peut pas répondre
financièrement, on peut aller en prison.
Il « s’enfuit ».
Il part à Paris et là,
il commence une nouvelle épopée.
Il rencontre Ozenfant, qui est un peintre.
Il lui permet de se lancer
dans la peinture.
Il développe, grâce au système domino que
vous avez déjà vu dans les pays du Sud,
ces ossatures en béton
qui permettent après de remplir
avec des briques l’ensemble du bâtiment.
On voit que dans ces années-là, ce qui
est très important, c’est la lumière.
Ce sont des éléments
qui sont fondamentaux pour lui.
La lumière et l’espace.
Il s’associe avec Jeanneret, un cousin
qui vient le rejoindre à Paris.
Ils ouvrent un bureau.
Il y a environ quatorze personnes
qui travaillent dans ce bureau.
C’est un grand bureau pour l’époque.
Là, ce que vous voyez, c’est la maison
mitoyenne Roche-Jeanneret, à Paris.
On était parti dans une petite villa
et on commence à avoir une mitoyenne.
On voit qu’il va jusqu’à Anvers
pour construire différents autres objets.
En 1932, la Villa Savoye,
qui lui permet de mettre
en pratique des principes,
les cinq points
d’une architecture nouvelle.
On le voit là, en fait,
ce sont des pilotis,
des fenêtres en bandeau.
Les pilotis permettent d’avoir une
structure indépendante des murs porteurs.
Et ça permet d’avoir plus de lumière
à l’intérieur des bâtiments.
Le toit terrasse, la façade
libre et le plan libre.
C'est ça que ça permet.
Après, à l’intérieur, avec les piliers,
on peut mettre des murs où on veut
et on peut avancer.
Il pose ces théories-là et
il les pose face à l’académisme.
Parce qu’à l’époque, quand on était
dans une école pour devenir architecte,
on suivait les préceptes
de l’école des Beaux-Arts,
avec tout le langage classique.
Il est devenu urbaniste aussi.
Il a eu plus de 40 projets urbains,
dont le plan Voisin
qu’il avait proposé pour Paris.
Heureusement, ça ne s’est pas [fait].
Ils ont refusé.
C’est André Malraux qui a réussi
à faire passer ça de côté
puisqu’il voulait démolir
une grande partie de Paris
pour proposer une ville de 3 millions
d’habitants avec des énormes tours
et des éléments qui lui tenaient à cœur :
la végétalisation,
les grands espaces, la mobilité
et les autres principes dont on a parlé
par rapport à ces machines à habiter.
Ensuite, il commence à avoir
une reconnaissance internationale.
Il commence à construire
de plus gros objets.
De plus en plus, il arrive
à se projeter par rapport à ça.
Point intéressant :
il continue de voyager.
D’ailleurs, une anecdote sympa, c’est
qu’en 1929, il part en Amérique du Sud
et quand il revient, il est dans
le même bateau que Joséphine Baker.
Ils font la fête sur le retour et tout...
À la fin, Joséphine lui dit :
« Vous êtes un amant formidable.
Dommage que vous soyez architecte. »
(Rires)
Il poursuit, il a différentes commandes.
Je n’ai pas mis toutes les réalisations
du Corbusier,
parce que ce serait être
très long d’être exhaustif.
J’ai choisi Tsentrosoyouz à Moscou
parce que c’est assez intéressant.
Sous Staline, un concours est lancé.
Il gagne le premier concours.
Mais Staline n’est pas content,
donc il lance un deuxième concours.
Il gagne le deuxième concours
et Staline n’est toujours pas content.
Donc il relance un concours et
Le Corbusier gagne une troisième fois.
C’est vraiment pour dire que cet homme,
il avait de l’abnégation.
Il allait jusqu'au bout de ses idées.
Il était certes intransigeant parfois,
et c’était difficile
de lui faire changer d’avis.
Mais c’est quelqu’un qui a,
sur le fil rouge de sa vie, suivi une idée
et l’a poursuivie
tout au long de sa carrière
pour aboutir à des objets d'exception.
Vous avez déjà entendu parler
de l’immeuble Clarté à Genève,
qui est actuellement une PPE,
une propriété par étage.
Vous avez entendu parler du concours
des Palais des Nations qu’il a gagné.
Les académiciens
n’étaient pas très contents,
donc ils ont trouvé
un élément du règlement.
Il devait rendre son dossier
dessiné à l’encre de Chine.
Lui était déjà en avant-garde
sur son temps,
donc il avait proposé du polycopié.
On l’a éliminé à cause de cela.
L’Unité d’habitation à Marseille, cette
Cité Radieuse ou la « Cité du Fada ».
C’est comme ça
que l’appellent les Marseillais.
Cette énorme bâtisse qu’il
a construite en cinq ans.
À l’intérieur, on avait des commerces,
on avait une école,
on avait une crèche, on avait des rues.
C’était vraiment un endroit
où on pouvait habiter
et partager différentes expériences,
pas seulement se loger.
Ce qui était intéressant,
vous le voyez tout en haut,
c’était l’idée des duplex.
Chaque appartement était en duplex.
Ça permettait de créer
entre les appartements une rue
qui permettait de desservir les logements.
Les typologies et l’expression
de ces éléments-là -
j’y reviendrais -
elles sont basées sur le Modulor.
C’est une unité de mesure qu’il avait
prise sur un homme de 1,83 m
et sur lequel il a différentes fois mis
les bras comme ci, les bras comme ça,
s'asseoir, etc.
Il a trouvé la bonne hauteur,
la bonne dimension
pour que l'être humain puisse habiter.
À la fin de sa vie, voilà qu’il reçoit
une commande en Inde à Chandigarh.
Là, il arrive à construire
un palais de justice,
une assemblée, un secrétariat.
Et ça, c'est véritablement
l'œuvre de sa vie.
Mais il continue toute sa vie
à construire,
à créer, à écrire, à peindre, à écrire.
Il y a une correspondance extraordinaire
entre lui, sa famille,
ses amis, son ancien professeur, etc.
Tout le monde a critiqué Le Corbusier.
Tout le monde critique évidemment les
artistes quand ils font quelque chose.
Le seul objet qui n'a pas été critiqué et
qui a été ovationné par tout le monde,
c’est la Dame de Ronchamp à Belfort,
juste à côté de chez nous.
Ici, vous faites 40 minutes de voiture
et vous avez une magnifique chapelle,
que vous pouvez visiter
et qui vaut véritablement le détour.
Le Couvent de la Tourette
que j’ai eu la chance de visiter
et même d’habiter pendant deux jours.
Vous avez des petites cellules,
vous vivez comme les moines.
C'est très particulier.
Les dimensions, ce sont celles
du Modulor du Corbusier.
C’est assez spartiate,
mais dans ce bâtiment-là, il a innové,
il a mis des canons de lumière,
il a mis différents éléments
qui lui permettaient d’innover
avec plus de créativité,
toujours plus d’idées
et plus de challenge,
qu’il proposait dans ses bâtiments.
L’église de Ferminy.
Il est mort en 65.
Elle a été réalisée post-mortem
par ses collègues
qui ont finalisé cette église.
Et également le Modulor, des meubles,
du design, de la peinture et du graphisme.
Donc aujourd’hui,
on a un gars qui a réussi
à réaliser 79 objets.
Il a 17 objets classés
au patrimoine de l’UNESCO.
Il a laissé 8000 dessins.
Il y a 400 peintures, il y a 37livres.
Qu’est-ce qu’on peut faire de plus ?
Comment est-ce qu’on peut véritablement
faire perdurer l’héritage du Corbusier ?
On a eu une idée
avec différents collègues.
On a lancé une association,
qui a vu le jour récemment,
pour créer un prix : Le Corbusier Prize,
un prix international d’architecture.
On aura un président du jury
de qualité mondiale
puisque c’est un Pritzker Prize.
On aura des jurys à travers le monde.
On va récompenser l’année prochaine -
on espère à la Chaux-de-Fonds -
le premier Le Corbusier Prize.
Et de cette manière-là,
nous espérons que nous allons
faire perdurer l’héritage du Corbusier,
pas en tant qu’objet, pas en tant
que livre, pas en tant que peinture,
pas en tant que fauteuil ou mobilier,
mais l’esprit du Corbusier :
sa créativité, son innovation.
Ce fut un des premiers
à parler de durabilité,
un des premiers
qui a mis en cause la mobilité,
qui mettait l’accent
sur la végétalisation.
On espère en octobre 2024
avoir nos premiers lauréats
que l'on pourra récompenser.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)